let's talk about probably one of the
craziest
maybe stupidest things
the the left faction that billionaires
could have done and it's the it's the
nominee joe biden sorry i mean this
seemed to work out for him so far but
we'll see how it plays out
check us out parlor is suing amazon for
suspending app from cloud service claims
anti-trust violation and breach of
contract parlor is seeking temporary
relief after after being blackballed by
amazon web services
a lot of people
actually let me slow down if you're not
familiar parlor is very much like
twitter
micro blogging platform where you get
followers you can make posts
and it was fast growing probably the
fastest it was the number one app on
itunes it was removed by itunes and by
apple and google it was then banned by
amazon amazon web services the
interesting thing a lot of people said
why would parlor use amazon web services
that's that's such a dumb thing to do
because of course they'll ban you that
you need to find your own web you know
servers or web hosting gab
which is also a micro blogging platform
created their own hosting system and
they're building their own
infrastructure so why would parlor use
amazon in fact i think it was the
smartest thing they could have done
because they had a contract with amazon
that if they're going to be terminated
they get 30 days which is enough time
for them to solve their problems and
move to a new you know provider
but what happens now is twitter was also
using amazon
so what do we get in this lawsuit it's
fascinating parlor says recently
amazon signed a multi-year hosting deal
with twitter
the parlor is fast becoming the number
one competition for
twitter amazon bans parlor so there's
clearly a conflict of interest and a
benefit for amazon's large massive and
valuable multi-year contract partner
but here's what they say
they claimed parlor wasn't enforcing
their rules more specifically they said
we don't believe they will enforce their
rules
there was i think something like 60 i
could be wrong there was a small handful
of posts that were inciting violence
parlor said in the suit we remove them
all immediately because they violate our
rules we do not allow incitement to
violence it is illegal
at the same time when amazon gave them
24 or or so hours to move their entire
platform violating breaching the
contract they had with them
hang mike pence was trending on twitter
and twitter did nothing and amazon said
nothing no public statement no threats
to twitter nothing we're also hearing
that they're trying to claim that these
people at the capitol were organizing on
parlor glenn greenwald said that's not
true they organized on facebook where
was anyone going after facebook at this
point it should be obvious to everybody
what's going on
we've seen it before with patreon this
is really fascinating when patreon
banned a bunch of people they all
flocked to subscribe star
which was a competitor to patreon so
what happened
payment processing companies i think
like paypal and stripe immediately
severed services to subscribe star
which shows what they're really trying
to do is to protect their monopolistic
power in silicon valley
there's no reason to ban parlor it was a
lie it has nothing to do with threats
they just grab a few screenshots and
they post them but i tell you what i can
go on twitter right now and probably
probably find 10 000
death threats and violence and i'll add
one more of the layer
while this is going on
i have personally filed
several complaints to twitter over
let's just call it extremely abusive
content directed at me and they have not
removed it can i now demand that amazon
ban twitter because i have been trying
to get stuff taken down that directly
threatens me and and and i'm going to
leave out specific details as to what
these posts are but they are some of the
it's it's bordering
i don't want to say too much i don't
want to reveal too much about what's
going on and why i'm having to report
people but it's serious it's very
serious threats twitter won't take them
down at least with parlor there was you
know to sign up for a twitter account
you just you know have a fake email with
parlor i think you needed to you know
have your uh your phone number and it
was kyc it's it's almost it's almost
easier
to track down somebody like i'm sure
that if
i i would i'm pretty sure that if
somebody if the doj came up to parlor
and said look this person is involved in
terrorism that they would go here here's
all the information we have you know uh
just well they said they were
cooperating with launch right so so to
to completely shut it down
and
move
those
bad conversations
to
you know to basically the the depths of
the internet at least on parlor you
could you could see it
wide open right so this is do you think
that and do you think the doj
is gonna go after amazon for anti-trust
over this nope hell no right twitter
harbors far leftists who to this day
have organized and called directly for
violence
no issues
none well well tim you know if you don't
like what amazon or google is doing you
should just build your own cia connected
monopoly multinational corporation you
know why didn't i think of that yes it's
that simple
that simple let me we'll call it you
want to get on yeah
let's do it
no but we've got to make some points
here i mean when we look at you know the
history of something like twitter and
facebook there's a long history of
people publishing information that hurt
other individuals so there's a long
history of people inciting violence
whether it's the arab spring or jihadis
or even the christ church town shooting
that was a live stream there was a
massacre live streamed by
a tech company that allowed the video to
go everywhere so when we're talking
about let's hold these companies
responsible for what they're doing um
that points back right at facebook that
points back right at twitter but it
essentially points back that no no we
can't set up this kind of president
where where people are responsible
because of what people do on
communication lines it's like the same
as charging at t because some jihadi
used their phone or used their company
to talk to another jihadi that makes
absolutely no sense at all what if you
left someone a voicemail threatening
them
would would the could you go after the
company for not deleting that voicemail
no but also
i mean remember uh maybe in the last two
years there was a group of
of uh of current and former
uh border patrol agents who had a
facebook group and they were all yes um
you know they were all sharing memes and
stuff and their i think pro publica came
out and showed like three all of three
examples you know out of out of tens of
thousands of posts
where you know they were attacking aoc
and and they were vile and they were
they were bad and you know and and
that's fine but you can't you can't then
lump everybody in right but then you you
didn't go
well facebook was sharing that so let's
penalize facebook uh what you know they
went after the group they went after
some of the people in it i think some
people probably got fired but it's the
same thing on parlor you can't go after
an entire platform just because there
are a couple you know bad apples right
and they were removing them it's the
same excuse they do with gab they're
like but they weren't really enforcing
their rules
did you go on there to make sure no well
they said they were enforcing them but
propublica said
but we found three people
you know
it happens every single time build your
own i love it because now at the point
where it's like every single vendor
start your own legal firm okay
they lost their lawyers
because
the the the as michael tracy said the
left liberal monoculture merging with
the state they have too much power they
control our lines of communication
they're controlling our commerce you
can't buy or trade if they ban you from
online uh payment processing what do you
do i guess bitcoin and this this is
where this is where okay
if you know amazon's history you'll
probably know that amazon for years
didn't make a profit they didn't make
they they didn't make a profit they also
weren't paying a lot in federal taxes
either uh but that's you know totally
legal
they were playing the long game they
were building their infrastructure they
were building warehouses all over the
place they were building these cloud
services anytime
netflix
goes offline
it's amazon's fault it's not netflix
it's because they're it's because
they're having issues with their with
their cloud services so
i can't remember what my point was but
[Laughter]
but
but yeah it's about being a gorilla yeah
well we have to understand that this
censorship is absolutely selective
there's despots there's dictators that
are still allowed to use twitter but
president donald trump can't and again
we have to also underscore that there's
a lot of international backlash when we
look at the market caps of facebook and
twitter they've been hit but there also
have been some leaders some presidents
coming out and speaking out against this
including
i'm really shocked by this angela merkel
the chancellor of germany came out and
she spoke out about how problematic it
is for tech companies to have so much
power that they're able to eliminate a
president from even having a voice
you're wrong no no you're wrong go ahead
angela merkel doesn't matter the mexican
president also uh
released some very surprising statements
angela merkel would mexican how do you
pronounce her name that's the only thing
you were wrong about okay it doesn't
matter angela who cares
oh my god
i'm going to keep butchering it
you know let's call the whole thing off
the the statements by the mexican
president were really surprising because
he went even further than that attacking
these tech companies as these
arbitrators of of truth and and
lambasting them for for such a move
which the mexican president is against
angela merkel is against the majority of
people are against because if you are
the morally superior voice you don't
need to silence other voices you would
debate you would argue you would have a
conversation with people and you would
prove your points it would be out there
in the open you wouldn't need to use the
tools of totalitarianism
in order to just squash any
ability for for words to hit other
people's ears that's just insane luke
you're wrong okay go ahead angela merkel
oh my gosh
i saw that coming
i don't care oh my god whatever watch a
train wreck
but you get my but you're right about
everything else but you're you're
completely correct yeah well i didn't
realize i didn't realize that the
mexican president was so based that he
is well the mexican president is very
surprising with his latest actions he he
wants to grant julian's assange asylum
he
is calling out the lockdown so it's he's
not just a kind of leftist figure he was
previously compared as a bernie sanders
but he's resisting a lot of the bigger
lockdowns and he's saying no you can't
just lock down small businesses you
can't lock down communities you can't
destroy people's livelihoods all in the
name of security because it's obviously
a big joke so seeing this happening in
mexico uh is is really surprising to say
the least i thought you're talking about
cuomo no no yeah yeah did release the
statement today como's always been for
protecting small businesses yeah andrew
cuomo recently came out and said we
can't keep this lockdown going on for
too much longer the election
we have to reopen and do it safely and
it's like you know what's really funny
is trump trump said something like you
know one day will disappear then there
are a bunch of leftists who are like all
of these these people were joking and
mocking the left saying that once the
election was over that covey would
disappear and here we are and it's like
jan january 6th just passed okay and now
cuomo has come out saying time to reopen
yep and buy it in two
but the opening is going to be done
based on your race according to joe
biden so that's all another whole issue
excuse me
tim cast is a minority-owned company
that's true yes it is happy to work here
that's right
so we get to reopen uh
not like we closed nobody really did
biden said it he's like we're going to
be prioritizing you know native american
black asian latina
can you say latinx i know i don't know
he probably did yeah
and then he said and women and then and
then everyone else it's like
what is everyone else after that white
men white men where's the asians he
didn't even mention asia he didn't know
i thought he did not mention asians what
nope he didn't no he didn't say asian
wait he probably didn't say asians he
probably said like
pacific no islander no he did now he did
what yeah unreal
no but we don't have to shut down anyway
so yeah whatever we're okay
yeah we still have a voice
good good for uh uh for him
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe hit the
like button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there thanks for hanging out and
we will see you all next time